so in the first game he uh magnus played
the english
so magnus is is is white here against
cecaro magnus is white against cicaro
and we see an english defense
[Music]
um and then knight c327 they repeated
the line now magnus doesn't go for d4
this time he goes for queen c
now what is the idea of queen c1 well
you know you're bringing the queen away
from the d file which means that later
on
the rook can occupy the defile and
perhaps prepare some d74 ideas now you
might say well
isn't this very far in the future thank
you yes
it is very far in the future but that's
how magnus plays he plays for the future
and the other thing that he can do here
is is support a potential knight
maneuver to c5
so knight t4 by hikar he's trying to nip
all this in the bud
takes takes 94. and here hikaru made the
decision that i thought was very
questionable i think that this is a
mistake
at least from a personal perspective i'm
not checking the computer
hikaru castles um now
his intention is very clear he wants to
checkmate magnus by playing h5h4 opening
up the h file
and playing bishop h3 but this is
i think a very good application of
something that i call a three move role
and i've introduced it before um in my
pogchamps coaching
and i talk about it a lot with my
students
um the three move rule is a very rough
guideline
by which you can assess whether or not
an idea
is realistically achievable in any given
position
now all things held equal in an
unbalanced position
if an idea takes three moves or longer
to achieve
from start to finish chances are unless
there are extenuating circumstances
such as the conspicuous absence of
counter play
um on the side of your opponent it's
probably unrealistic
okay now obviously there are tons of
exceptions to this rule but it is
kind of i think a pretty faithful
guideline that can allow you to assess
certain types of ideas now h5 if you
think about it
one two three
now we can say three and a half because
white's probably going to recapture
three and a half four and only on the
fourth move
does black finally penetrate then with
queen h3
so in a situation like this a form of
idea
to me is just not very achievable
um and the same thing goes for maneuvers
if you're
orchestrating a maneuver that takes
three moves or longer
that doesn't mean you can't do it you
just got to be very careful about
properly anticipating your opponent's
counterplay
so what should nakamura have done here
um i'm not a specialist in these types
of positions but i'm thinking c6 perhaps
comes to mind
in order to blunt uh the influence of
the bishop
fatal owl well those are two entirely
entirely different things
the move queen c1 prepares a potential
move
by the way which is only one move okay
i'm not saying he's going to play it and
even if he does play it it abides by
the three move rule rook d1 is only one
move now
here i'm not saying don't think ahead
i'm talking specifically about the
length of a specific plan
um and discussing the length of the plan
versus
opening up a potential idea those two
things are i did yeah yes 111 thank you
for the sub
uh my apologies if i missed it so
i think that c6 might have made some
sense
castles and of course magnus plays a4
and obviously
in in such positions you ignore uh the
pawn on b3 i mean
getting worried about bishop takes b3
would be quite ridiculous
now what to do in this position
it's actually you know when you plug
these positions into the computer you
begin to realize that oftentimes
one could even take a pawn like this
sometimes with impunity
but for a human to do so is virtually
impossible i think that after a5 knight
c4
white could even play this very slowly
he could play d3 perhaps
and after knight takes b2 queen takes b2
bishop d5
y could pile up on this b7 pawn
by means of rook rookie to b1 for
example and even a position like this
just seems to me to be very very
difficult to defend as you guys can
understand and i already see some very
interesting ideas
connected with uh knight f6 and what's
the follow-up guys here
what's the follow-up here i mean i white
only draws with this but it's still a
beautiful idea i think
very typical concept by the way when you
have so many pieces piled up on
the b7 square and this is especially
true when the king is castled long
so dr lono queen d4 is not enough it's
like
you're you're not putting enough a1
sauce on the stake i'll play c5 and i'll
chase you away remember you've
sacrificed a piece
so instead you have to sack the queen
and now you have a very typical draw
if you take the queen you'll be down a
piece you could play rook bhek just for
architectural purposes and then you can
force the draw
but you can't do any more than that
unfortunately it's a windmill but
there's no
grist you know there's no grist for the
mill you you can't take any pieces
with the windmill so it's like an empty
windmill anyways
so that's the reason i think hikaru
didn't take the pawnee cargo's d3
which is a move we saw in that aborted
game i was showing trying to
you know do something a5 by magnus
counter attacking the knight knight t5
by hikaru now once again e takes d3
um peanuts i mean this is peanuts when
magnus has won the lottery
and you don't want to bog yourself down
and take these useless pawns
notice that dxe2 is easily immobilized
by rookie one this pawn is not to be
word not to be afraid of so
knight c5 by magnus as we discussed that
was the preliminary idea of queen c1 i
hope this is making sense so far
you guys are welcome to stop me with any
questions you might have i love
answering questions
takes takes king b8 and magnus now pays
attention to the spot on a7 he notices
that the queen
is making contact with it he notices
that there is a potential battery
and he puts the pieces of the puzzle
together forcing a tremendous concession
on the part of hikaru
the move v6 which obviously not only
does it open up the diagonal but it also
opens up the file
and at this point in the commentary i
thought that the checkmate would be a
matter of five ten moves
but we all know that hikaru is an
incredible defender
and he's an incredible defender not only
because of the objective resilience of
his ideas but because he forces the
opponents
essentially to find tremendously precise
sequences of moves
it's not that hikaru is a magician
in the sense that you know you can beat
him it's just he'll make you find
five only moves in a row and he'll find
the only defensive sequence
uh under which that is indeed the case
so queen a3 d takes c2 rook fp1 of
course
hikaru plays rook c8 and what he's
trying to do with this move is bring the
rook to c7 why is he bringing the rook
to c7 well
he doesn't want his queen to be tied
down to the defense of the a7 pawn
now why is it bad for a queen to be tied
down to the defensive upon because it's
a goddamn queen
you want your queen to to do more than
just
you know supervise an impotent pawn you
want the queen to at least participate
in the action
in an appreciable way so is it good to
have the rook tied down to the pawn no
but at least it's better than having the
queen tied down to it
takes um rook c7
and now we see a very interesting move
from magnus rook e1 and one might
think well why the hell is he removing
his rook from
the file on which he seems to be
attacking well chess
is a very multi-dimensional game
you know first of all he's preparing a
brilliant tactic that i'm going to
unpack that he plays in the next move
in my view it was brilliant but in in
addition notice that the rook can
potentially penetrate the e8
or perhaps the e7 so he's shifting
the focus over to the center trying to
overextend black
who has just expended all of his
resources on queen side defense
of course he's also threatening the
bishop and the bishop is defending the
knight so this entire mechanism is very
flimsy bishop h3 by nakamura of course
hikaru trying hoping against hope to
trade off the light squirt bishops
and here magnus plays a brilliant
sacrifice now in the commentary we saw
this move we saw the possibility of this
move it flows naturally from this
position
when you have all of your pieces
participating in a game like this
it's natural that you're going to have
some sort of tactical blow and you need
to be actively looking for one
and one manifest itself in the form of
bishop takes p6
ripping into black's queen side bond
structure now what what is the idea
black has three recaptures
bishop takes g2 is the easiest recapture
to refute what does white do in this
position folks
bishop takes rook check very simple
intermezzo
take and we not only have a very good
attack but we have an extra exchange
so that one doesn't work a takes b6
now it's very important when you're
evaluating this position to understand
how the position
changes as a consequence of your last
move a takes b6
opens up the a file which means
immediately we conclude
this knight on d5 is pinned and this is
by the way a pin
okay it might not be a pin you're used
to but this is a pin because the knight
cannot move due to mate
so we can use that fact to play what
move
what move flows naturally when we
realize that the knight on d5 isn't
actually controlling any squares
yeah you guys are on the ball as always
rookie seven now in these situations
you want to be extremely disciplined
about calculating everything so
if black's queen drops back to d8 for
example
well among other things here white can
consider the simple
rook takes c7 followed by bishop takes
h3 and white
is a pawn up and he's going to move the
bishop back to g2 and he's got a
crushing attack
now if black tries queen takes c7 it's
very important to point out
that rook c1 would have been checkmate
had the queen not been on a3 so you see
how important it is
to position your pieces harmoniously
when you do so
you know you get various bonuses from
their placement now if knight takes c7
of course
checkmate and if rook takes c7
it's very important in these positions
not to rush do not
rush to capture the bishop on h3 check
first for intermediate moves
when the king is wide open like this you
always want to check for intermediate
moves before you capture a piece
and an intermediate move indeed
presents itself if you look for one in
the form of queen d6 check
introducing complete cacophony within
black's ranks total discord bishop takes
h3
the knight is lost the knight is
literally almost trapped and if it moves
then queen takes b6 follows
with devastating effect remember that
white still has this bishop and black
still has
huge weaknesses on the light squares so
hopefully that makes sense
which leaves us of course with the
sacrifice night with the recapture
knight takes b6
rookie 7 follows nonetheless and ikaro
as one international master like to say
if i'm gonna die i'm gonna die with a
full stomach at least i'm gonna die with
a full stomach so hicaro at the very
least takes a pawn
and that's why he put his rook on c7 now
he activates his queen
and at the very least he reestablishes
material
equality after bishop takes h3 he brings
his whoops sorry
mr bishop takes h3 he brings his final
rook into the game with rook d8
um his play hinges on the fact that rook
takes c7 meets with another intermezzo
queen takes e1 check followed by king
takes c7
and um this is the point at which magnus
well a couple of moves from now
is where magnus really started to
surprise everyone in the commentary
booth
queen a6 makes sense okay bringing the
queen in
controlling the b7 square preparing a
potential bishop g2
hikaru takes and ikaru gives
a check on d1 why does he give this
check because
if the king moves up to g2 then he
checks him again
and this is a dual purpose move not only
is this a check but the queen drops back
and covers the b7 square
now while this is very nasty um black
can stay alive and after king g1 he
continues to repeat the position so
magnus
saved time by playing bishop f1
immediately
rook d7 followed cutting off the
influence of the rook
had uh magnus had igaro defended with
queen d5 what would have hikaru done
here
is this even a defense is this even a
defense
this is a cloud this would be a classic
example of tunnel vision
because it's very easy to only pay
attention to the b7 square
but look at the entire range of of
squares
queen takes a 7 check is just make ice
and it's very easy to miss this mate
it's very obvious but it's very easy to
miss
because in focusing on one square you
frequently miss the fact that there are
other squares that are involved in the
attack
so try to refrain from that when you're
playing would be i think a piece of
advice i would share
so hikaru therefore plays rook d7 rookie
a check rook t8
rookie 3 why has magnus played the
rookie check before playing rookie three
because
it's important to ward black stroke off
the seventh rank where it was fulfilling
a very important defensive duty uh
guarding these
squares rookie three and hikaru plays
a very typical hikaru move very very
strong defensive move h5
and this is one of those moves that i
feel like a lot of players see and get
intimidated
and they assume that you will never be
able to understand a move like this but
my goal is to help you guys every one of
you understand why he made this move
now first of all it's important to
understand
that in such positions when you're
trying to defend them you want to ask
yourself
where the danger is coming from what is
your opponent's
main plan of action going to be now
if you look at this position right now
what is the main thing
that's holding magnus back can you guys
answer that question for me
what is the main thing that's holding
without this thing
magnus would essentially be mating on
the spot what is that
thing
yeah so had three za is pointing out
correctly
the pin bishop it's the pin bishop now
imagine if the bishop wasn't pinned well
we'd play bishop g2 and the game would
be over i mean how could white defend
how could black defend that is against
such a monster bishop
now then we ask ourselves the next
question working backwards
does white have a plan that will enable
him to extricate his bishop
but i'm not looking for king g2 we
already know that that move runs into
queen d5 track
how is he going to extricate the bishop
such that the bishop can then land on g2
he's got a plan
he's got a plan for doing so what is
that plan i need to run in the bathroom
guys
i will be right back in the meantime
think about what magnus's plan is in
this position
for liberating the bishop and how
hikaru's move final step of the logical
chain
either discourages or entirely precludes
magnus from accomplishing
that plan i'll be right back guys simply
h4
king h2 and bishop g2 no i understand
i understand i'm not saying it's easy h4
king king h2 and bishop g2
now a couple of you suggested f3 and
king f2 but that would
block the long diagonal remember the
bishop wants to come to g2
so hikaru plays the move h5 now
how does this prevent or discourage this
idea well magnus plays h4
the idea of the move h5 will be revealed
only when we look at the next move okay
the next move is g5 so what hikaru is
trying to do here
is to discard is to uh
start off an attack against white's
newly created pawn weakness on h4
i call it a hook so that white will not
be able to play king h2 bishop g2 in
succession he will have to distract his
attention
on doing things like h takes g5 so
i actually think that g5 immediately
would have also been possible
that would have perhaps been a more
clear way of preventing the move h4
but i think the reason nicaragua plays
h5 is because he was worried magnus
would play h3
and which weakening move does hikaru now
have at his disposal
that can weaken the position of white's
king that this is why he played h5 and
not g5
and i'm explaining he can play h4 now
you i hear you guys saying why the hell
does this matter why plays g4
well it does matter because notice this
diagonal let's say black plays a random
move
now after king h2 what move does black
have what additional resource does black
have
this is is this is the brilliance of
this
uh defensive idea
very nicely guys queen d6 check and
without this move h4 without this
provocation
this check would not have been possible
so that is the ultimate point of h5
it's a three-step logical process what
is white's idea
how does he accomplish it how can i
prevent it and that last step
is where people obviously struggle a
very very strong defensive idea indeed
h4 by magnus g5 now this is where
this is where i was a little bit
surprised now
i thought that magnus could still play
king h2
and simply ignore the capture of ikaro
and go bishop g2
and reach this position where it is
true that hikaru has taken at least one
of magnus's pawn so i will die with a
full stomach
but magnus has a crushing tactical blow
here now that he has made contact with
the b7 pawn
we have a typical case of overloading
the queen on d7
is tied down to the defense of this
square
we can use that to distract the queen
and win on the spot
rook d3 is easy you could not take the
rook
checkmate if you move the queen
then rook takes d a queen takes the a
and queen b7 check so in the commentary
i spotted this
um i spotted this and we were both
shocked that
magnus did not play king h2 now this is
very uncharacteristic
i don't know i'm not looking with the
computer but i am pretty much positive
that king h2 would have been correct
here
okay and when you talk about bad form
and you want to define it this is what
bad form is this is what bad form is
magnus missing rook d3 is inexplicable
um that's like lebron missing a layup
does lebron miss layups he does
absolutely does and we shouldn't hold it
against lebron for missing the
occasional lamp
that's why the people sitting in their
armchairs looking at the computer evil
should not bury magnus for missing this
he's a human being
human beings have off games but
that's why i feel like he lacks some
confidence i feel like h takes g5 is
is stems from a fundamental lack of
confidence
in his ability to sack the pawn and
evaluate that position correctly
now here again king h2 was possible but
now the situation is
greatly complicated because after h
takes g3 check
f takes g3 what additional set of
resources
does black have in this position in fact
at this point black is already winning
with the following move and this shows
how important it is
to pay attention to the tiniest details
because they inform your knowledge of
the position
rocket shape almost checkmate and after
bishop h3 we checkmate the bishop with
g4
okay so in any case
at this point it's a day late and a
dollar short or
yeah i think that's how it goes rookie 7
rook d7
again notice how white is greatly
circums white's potential to win this
game is impeded
to the greatest effect by the fact that
the bishop is paralyzed
that's why it's so important to identify
what's holding you back
rookie a czech rook t8 and magnus
signaling the failure of a strategy
ghost queen b5 and at this point
it's already become clear that he has
relinquished the immediate attack
against black's king
instead he's switching his attention to
the newly created pawn weaknesses
and hikaru once again reacts very very
accurately
rather than panicking he goes h4
he goes h4 and the problem for white is
that he cannot capture on g5 because a
brook takes the a
and what curses uh magnus is that if he
first takes the rook
then not only does the queen capture the
rook but simultaneously it defends not
one but
both pawns and the game ends quickly in
a draw
so magnus after a series of checks well
he gave a check here
he goes rookie six trying to somehow
orchestrate
some sort of checkmating operation and
ikaro fearlessly
and correctly takes on g3 it's very
important to understand the king is not
an easy piece to checkmate
why is this not checkmate where does
black's king escape to what square
guarantees the king an escape this was
not a must win this was the first game
of their mini match
well ultimately ultimately ultimately a8
yeah ultimately the king escapes the a8
ultimately the king escapes to a8 where
it's safe sound
on a beach somewhere in maui
and that's what happens magnus returns
to take the pawn
any caro finds yet another brilliant
defensive resource this one to save the
game
he activates his knight with knight t5
now this move is not so surprising until
you realize
that he seems to have blundered upon not
only has he seemed to blunder upon
but he's done so while attacking the
rook on d8 let's not forget
white can use his extra pawn now to
transform the game into an end game
which is going to be tremendously
difficult to defend but hikaru once
again exploiting the pin against black's
bishop
and exploiting the newly created g-file
combining those two factors together
if we think very hard about how we can
combine those factors together
we find the move it's not a very
difficult tactic why don't you guys take
a stab at it
knight e3 is not correct guys because
what you're missing is that i have a
pawn here on f2 i'm not going to
cooperate with queen takes c3 that's the
right idea
but you have to find the right execution
i simply take with a pawn
so you play not knight e3 but knight f4
what you're threatening is knight h3
check exploiting what the pin once again
to work the queen black's got a bunch of
pieces here all attacking the white king
magnus says nothing better than to take
the knight check
takes f1 notice that this is not
checkmate this would actually lose the
game due to bishop h3
thank you dylan and the simple fact of
the matter is that white no longer has
enough material
to inflict any kind of damage against
black skin the a7 pawn lends sufficient
cover
for black's king and the problem here is
that while magnus plays rook h6 he's
trying
to create some intrigue but hikaru is
simply way too active
in fact magnus is really playing with
fire here you know under under a
different set of circumstances he could
have gotten checkmated
but finally here magnus acquiesces to
the inevitable
and orchestrates a very long three-time
repetition gives a bunch of checks
but at the end of the day he takes the
draw because notice that
white simply has no way to make progress
with such a weak king
any other move that's not a check would
essentially get checkmated
so that is how hikaru pulled off a
miracle draw in the first game
using some brilliant defensive resources
so the opening was really amazing for
magnus bishop takes b6 an
incredible move really um but
what hikaru did here if you guys noticed
this is what i said at the start
he forced magnus to find an only series
of moves
because i believe that king h2 was the
only clean point at which magnus could
have won the game
this was the only point in which magnus
could have won the game after he took on
g5
while he might have still been better
i'm sure he was
um i didn't see a clear-cut win and in
there and lies the essence i would say
of what makes icaru among other things
very good at blitz and rapid
is the fact that he puts in front of his
opponents tremendous
difficulties in the sense that he forces
his opponent to play precisely
you guys can check the engine yourselves
i personally
make the choice of enjoying the games
myself
and to me the process of discovering
things on my own even if it entails
mistakes
is infinitely more satisfying than
checking the computer and feeling proud
of myself when i just checked the
evaluation and
if you guys are serious about about
improvements i would encourage you to do
the same thing although
each person chooses for themselves